je vais prendre le contrôle ni terre en
la nuit on s'adresse les premiers
ajustements un reflet sur le portable
qui sème le doute
mais finalement les voyants sont au vert
l'accès au restaurant est autorisée
problème ces mois de juin problème a pas
de souci le restaurant emile et lola de
l'hôtel mercure situé en plein coeur de
la ville de metz se prépare depuis le
lundi 26 juillet à l'instauration d'une
règle qui va changer la vie de nombreux
clients et employés
à partir d'une foot se faire vacciner se
faire tester puis contrôlé prendre un
repas ou un verre deviendra donc plus
compliqué mais les restaurateurs veulent
croire à un renouveau après plus d'un an
de souffrance déjà la liberté pour nous
cette servir
avant on était obligé de fermer dans les
cadres confinement bon pour nous le pass
sanitaire c'est plutôt une ouverture et
et
une action liberté alors après nous ne
souhaitions pas contrôler les cartes
d'identité parce que c'est pas notre
métier et puis on hamm est plutôt un
métier l'hospitalité de discrétion
habituellement donc ça change nos
habitudes mais je pense qu'il est
nécessaire pour nos activités ce qu'on
veut à tout prix c'est ne pas refermer
ne pas refermer également la porte aux
clients non vaccinés autorisés à
consommer sont pas sanitaire jusqu'à son
entrée en vigueur officielle aujourd'hui
il est question de compréhension et de
préparation cinq établissements
différents se prête au jeu
bar à cocktail bar à bières ou encore un
restaurant un fort densité de clients
comme la crêperie le saint malo
vous moi j'estime qu'en fait on a des
jambes peuvent ne pas se faire vacciner
mais à ce compte là il faut aussi qu'ils
respectent les autres elle la crêperie
le saint malo tancé ces dernières heures
sur les réseaux sociaux pour son
initiative une trés prix qui a vu sa
note baissée sur des sites spécialisés
même hôtel bonne encore hier des gens
qui ne comprennent pas qu'on était des
collabos des fashion tout ce qu'on veut
donc si vous voulez ça devient pénible
on n'a pas le choix c'est ça ou on ferme
est bon les gens comprennent pas donc ça
peut je comprends qu'ils veulent pas
faire avec cela mais qu'il est sa
liberté aux autres de venir manger
tranquillement interrogations chez les
clients tout comme chez les employés au
sein du coffee shops le fox le futur
changement s'annonce compliquée alors
bien sûr on va s'adapter à ce qu'on nous
demande de fermer
ça va être une gestion plutôt
catastrophique je pense on nous demande
de faire un métier de policier des mines
d'embaucher quelqu'un à plein temps pour
pouvoir gérer l'affluence c'est quelque
chose d'assez d' assez stressant pour
nous un établissement qui se réjouit
tout de même que l'intégralité de ses
employés est accepté de se faire
vacciner
ces derniers ont jusqu'au 30 août pour
se munir d'un passait ni terre afin
d'éviter une suspension de salaire la
prise d'un congé sans solde ou encore
une réaffectation professionnels